hello everyone it's seven o'clock sexual
harassment sexual assault and
discreditable conduct Behavior details
by women about police officers who are
meant to be helping them it's another
report which will pile more pressure
onto police Chiefs trying to win back
the Public's confidence we'll have the
full details of the report and reaction
plus Britain teams up with the UK and
Australia to patrol the seas in a new
Global defense partnership we'll hear
from security minister Tom tuckenhaus
and later from Labor's tulip City
it's Tuesday the 14th of March
just a fraction of police officers
facing complaints about their treatment
of women are sacked according to a new
report a victim tells us they've lost
confidence in the police
I might disclosing to a decent police
officer or am I disclosing to a
perpetrator police officer we recognize
that the trust of women and girls across
this country is really really broken
a show of strength to counter Chinese
influence the UK U.S and Australia
announced plans for a new generation of
nuclear-powered attack submarines
global banking stocks slump despite a
pledge from President Biden to protect
the U.S banking system and the rescue of
the UK arm of Silicon Valley Bank
Gary Glitter is returned to prison for
breaking licensed conditions as a report
says the prison probation system simply
isn't working
little Unity as the S P's three
leadership candidates clash in a live
Sky News debate
also this morning so Steve Redgrave is a
man who likes to win today he'll tell us
how he's helping others battling against
diabetes
and we meet the team setting off on a 3
000 mile journey through What's called
the Great Pacific Garbage Patch
highlighting the state of the world's
oceans
[Music]
hello good morning there's more pressure
on police Chiefs this morning with the
Revelation that more than a thousand
complaints were made against police
officers and staff about their treatment
of women hundreds of the complaints
involved violence against women and
girls others involved sexual assault
harassment and overbearing Behavior get
just a tiny fraction fewer than one
percent of those who faced complaints
were sacked here's Becky Johnson
he stood about three foot away from me
pointing the gun at my chest uh told me
he loved me and pulled the first trigger
Rachel's husband nearly killed her after
18 years of abuse she now supports other
victims of domestic violence but says
many women are losing faith in the
police
people don't feel safe reporting to the
police because of everything that's
happened over the last couple of years
what's the point in disclosing you know
am I disclosing to a decent police
officer or am I disclosing to a
perpetrator police officer in the six
months to last March more than 1500
police officers and staff in England and
Wales were investigated over concerns
about their treatment of women that's
0.7 percent of the entire police
Workforce less than one percent of those
investigated were sacked what is he
searching for articles writing to the
offenses in Saint Albans in 2020 this
this is the allegation that's been made
to us okay sir high profile cases like
met police officer David Carrick who was
jailed for a series of rapes and Wayne
cousins who murdered Sarah everard have
led police to acknowledge that women
have lost confidence in officers we
recognize that the trust of women and
girls across this country is really
really broken we want to show that we
are indeed shining that light that we
will continue to do so and that we will
do all we can to remove people who
shouldn't be working within policing but
we will do all that we can with other
parts of the system to improve the
criminal justice response in
leicestershire a new team of officers
are trying to change the culture it's
about acknowledging that using victim
blaming or minimizing language is
absolutely not acceptable but also that
sometimes it creates a barrier that
prevents people from feeling that we are
the right people to deal with their
complaints if trust in police is not
restored there's a risk women will feel
they have nowhere to turn Becky Johnson
Sky News
the UK has confirmed a deal to work with
the United States and Australia to build
a new generation of nuclear attack
submarines the agreement will create
thousands of jobs in UK shipyards while
helping Australia counter Chinese
activities in the Pacific where she soon
act joined U.S President Joe Biden in
California where he claimed it was the
most significant multilateral defense
partnership in Generations
for the first time ever it will mean
three fleets of submarines working
together across both the Atlantic and
Pacific keeping our oceans free open and
prosperous for decades to come
Australian United Kingdom are of two of
America's most stalwart and capable
allies our common values our shared
Vision more peaceful and prosperous
future unite us all across the Atlantic
and Pacific
for more than a century you 've stood
together to defend freedom and
strengthen democracy
well a political correspondent tomorrow
Conan is here tomorrow this is a lot of
money isn't it why does the government
think it's a good investment well I
think this symbolism for Richard Cena is
important the three Western leaders
standing there overlooking the Pacific
in San Diego and some bolstering
relations across the Atlantic I think
that will be extremely important for him
we knew about this deal 18 months ago
now we have the details it will involve
a UK designed submarine and it's a
20-year long project it will take a very
long time for these submarines to be
built in the UK and Australia and them
to be up and running but the Prime
Minister we know from the integrated
review that he set out yesterday
believes that China is a big challenge
he didn't use the word threat and this
is the Western democracies working
together to counter the challenge posed
by China in the indo-pacific region now
the criticism that was made yesterday is
that he's announced another five billion
pounds for the defense budget less than
his defense secretary had wanted and it
transpired that about three billion of
that is going on our own nuclear
deterrence so not much for the Army and
we're already seeing defense Chiefs
today saying look the Army's had its
numbers cut been hollowed out some say
over the last few years and this doesn't
really
um redress the balance labor also saying
that when they were in power back in
2010 defense spending was a higher level
than it is now so yes he is boosting
alliances but there's questions about
whether he's spending enough back home
also of course this week the big
political Story the budget which is
happening tomorrow we're getting a few
things drip read about it one of about
pensions
um it's it's for those who are saving a
pension pot and have a lot of money the
government's going to increase it who
will benefit from this it's a backdrop
to tomorrow's budget which is Jeremy
Hunt's first budget is it's not going to
be exciting Good News it's not going to
be big spending you're not going to see
loads of tax cuts because it's important
he says to cut inflation and debt those
are the government's priorities it's
very steady as they go but after the
last few few budgets a boring budget a
lot of people would so it'd be quite a
good thing I think that's what the
government's are hoping for but of
course are they going to have calls from
people where's the economic growth going
to come from now we have one of the big
priorities for the government is to get
people who are economically inactive who
could work but aren't back into work and
we've seen big trail in the newspapers
today the treasury won't comment on it
but it's a pretty detailed uh story that
the lifetime allowance the amount that
people can put tax-free essentially in
their pension is going to go up from a
million pounds which is the cap at the
moment to its claimed today one and a
half million pounds so quite a big
increase and be quite a hefty increase
in the allowance that you can put in
every year from forty thousand to sixty
thousand so this is perhaps aimed at
getting those like doctors for example
who have taken early retirement back
into work but of course you're giving a
big tax break to people who are already
quite wealthy where it doesn't sound
like many people near the bottom of the
scale are going to be getting much into
tomorrow's budget yeah they'd be lucky
to put anything on a pension at all
tomorrow thanks very much well we will
of course have full coverage of the
budget on Sky News tomorrow and we want
to hear your thoughts about it one of
the Chancellor's plans make a difference
to your finances has Jeremy Hunt done
too many much or too little and how has
the cost of living been affecting you
you can contact us on o2o
8167-2200 to be part of a special
program the budget you'll say taking
place on Wednesday at seven o'clock here
on Sky News
now the government's Bill to implement
its new migration policy has passed its
second reading in the House of Commons
it aims to stop small boats illegally
crossing the channel but was challenged
by some conservative back benches
including the former prime minister
Theresa May
anybody who thinks that this bill will
deal with the issue of illegal migration
once and for raw is wrong not least
because a significant number if not the
majority of people who are here
illegally don't come on small boats they
come legally and overstay their visas
well the Prime Minister was in
California as the bill went through the
house but had this to say
I'm confident that our bill represents
the best way to grip this problem I've
also always been clear that there is no
overnight easy one simple solution to
what is a complicated problem it will
take lots of different interventions and
that's what we're doing
latest unemployment figures have just
been released our business correspondent
corporate no one is here to talk us
through the figures what do they tell us
yeah so these figures out today by the
ons they show redundancies are rising
vacancies are falling all of which
points to a Slowdown in the economy now
this hasn't yet fed into a higher
unemployment rate the unemployment rate
was stable at 3.7 but if you look at the
raw numbers the number of people who are
actually unemployed in the economy that
Rose and so that is going to start
feeding into the unemployment rate over
the coming months it's going to start
climbing and the bank of England sees it
hitting somewhere in the region of 6.5
which is a lot higher than it's been in
recent years now firstly the bank of
England is actually looking for signs of
weakness in the labor market because it
may take some of the pressure off the
central bank to raise interest rates now
if the labor market is running too hot
and crucially if wages are rising too
robustly policy makers fear that that
could fuel inflation so all of this
suggests that things are sort of playing
out as the bank of England expected okay
um the collapse of the svb bank though
of course that wasn't expected that sort
of obviously hit the news over the
weekend should we be keeping an eye on
stocks and shares today will there be
more fall out from it do you think yeah
and actually I mean I just touched on
interest rates but this also matters for
interest rates because what it's showing
is that Rising interest rates in the
economy are starting to now cause some
damage so just a few days ago financial
markets were pricing in
almost certain they were almost certain
that the bank of England was going to
raise interest rates at its next
monetary policy uh meeting that's now
come down to just 70 percent and there
are similar lower expectations for the
U.S federal reserve as well so all of
this suggests that the tide could now
start to turn on interest rates and they
could start coming down because it's a
risk that is undermining Financial
stability okay thanks very much
now Junior doctors on strike for the
second of three days the British Medical
Association says Junior doctors pay has
fallen in real terms by 26 since 2009.
tens of thousands of appointments and
operations are expected to be canceled
across England as a result of the
72-hour walkout
BBC bosses are coming under Fire from
some conservative MPS following their
decision to reinstate Gary lineker to
match of the day a number of MPS claim
the corporation has given in to the
presenter an independent review is to be
held into the BBC's social media
guidelines as a result of The Showdown
President Biden says he intends to visit
Northern Ireland and Ireland to Mark the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement in April the invitation from
prime minister Richie sinak followed the
pair meeting in San Diego to announce a
nuclear submarine deal with Australia
because
Carrie glitter is back in prison this
morning following a breach of his
license conditions the 79 year old was
freed last month after serving half of a
16-year jail sentence his recall comes
as the prison's inspector reports that
the release of prisoners under the
probation system simply isn't working
here with me now is Sky's shiman Freeman
Powell and and Shimon first of all Gary
Glitter record to prison after just a
matter of days yeah lots of our viewers
will remember at the time that there
were actually protests once he was
released one because he had been
released to a hostel which was in a
residential area and because there had
been concern that he had been freed
after a only serving half of his
sentence however at the time the
probation service were very keen to
stress that he was being closely
monitored this of course is a man that
is one of Britain's most high profile
sex offenders who was preying on
vulnerable school children so the
probation service are very keen to
reflect the fact that he had been
closely monitored and had been placed on
tag and now we're learning that after
just under six weeks he has now been
recalled back to prison and this news
comes as a report's been released today
which really has raises concerns over
the effectiveness of the probation
service it found that most or many that
are released find it very difficult to
integrate into normal life the report
found that fewer than one in ten of
those available for work went into
employment recall rates were high with
around three in ten released on Prison
being returned to custody and in some
regions almost half of those individuals
were sent back to prison interestingly
as well the report found that many of
the recalls were not actually for
reoffending rather it was full breaching
those licensing conditions and actually
a lot in a lot of these cases
vulnerabilities were involved such as
drug misuse homelessness and lack of
continuity care so there has been
recommendations to improve some of those
issues namely to improve Staffing and to
ensure that that continuity of care is
is happening I'm going to be talking
about this in a little bit more detail
later on this hour thanks very much
members of the Scottish national party
have started voting for the successor to
Nicola sturgeon and if they watched the
debate between the three candidates
vying to replace as first Minister last
night I would have seen little Unity on
show a political editor Beth Rigby
chaired the debate and has this report
sorry Hi candidates arrive in the stage
was set voting now underway three
contenders with pictures looking to
become Scotland's next first minister
fast and awkward concession from Ash
Regan as she failed to explain what's
needed to set up an independent currency
so you need a central bank what about
the other institutions you need
what other institutions are you talking
about you don't know
the independent debt management office
right I'm sure as I said I don't have
this detail on this at the moment for
Kate Forbes it was yet again on social
issues where she lacked Clarity or
should be allowed to live freely as they
choose and I do not think that there
should be a that there should be
conversion therapy gay man adult man if
he wants therapy to change his sexuality
should that be allowed or not well it's
it's it's it's his choice and but I do
not think we should allow conversions to
this Choice well we should not allow
conversion therapy in Scotland
tried to exploit a perceived weakness of
misforbs a party once famous for its
Unity its discipline now on the attack
isn't the reason you're losing SMP
support is because as that exchange with
bethashron you're not able to give a
really straight answer to a really
straight question on our Progressive
agenda and that's going to lose our
support Hamza Yusuf now Health Minister
but previously transport and Justice
this a domestic record he was forced to
defend good governance matters so a good
Health Service matters dealing with the
economy matters I mean what would you do
to deliver for example economic growth
in our economy and why do you think I'm
more trusted to tackle the cost of
living Christ that's what I suspect
because you've not had a public service
delivery at all but I've had three of
the most difficult in government over
the last 10 and a half years how are you
going to deliver Independence if the
public don't have confidence in you they
do and for three weeks I've managed to
increase public support quadrupled in
fact an hour as much about division as
it was detail or policy by the end of
the month one of them will become leader
there's a lot of patching up to do beth
Rigby Sky News Edinburgh
thank you
and I'm going to be talking to Stephen
Flynn the SNP Westminster leader after 7
30 for more on that debate
let's take a look at some of today's
other headlines now and more than 100
people have been killed in Malawi and
Mozambique as Cyclone Freddy continues
to batter southern Africa local police
have said a three-year-old who got
trapped in the debris is among the
victims it's the second time the
record-breaking Cyclone has made
landfall in Mainland Africa
North Korea has fired two short-range
ballistic missiles into Waters off its
East Coast in its second show of
strength this week as South Korea and
the United States conduct their biggest
military exercises in years
North Korea also launched two missiles
from a submarine on Sunday and last week
their leader Kim Jong-un ordered his
troops to be ready to repel what he
called frantic wall preparations moves
China is to start reissuing visas to
foreigners from tomorrow it's the final
cross-border control measure it imposed
three years ago during the height of the
pandemic
now the UK has confirmed a deal to work
with the United States and Australia to
build a new generation of nuclear attack
submarines join me now security minister
Tom tugenhart a good to see you Tom
um very well the
these submarines of course the orcas
pack
all about strengthening relations
between Australia America and the UK but
also about looking at the threat that
Australia faces China
very high up on that threat is the UK
government being a bit soft on China at
the moment no I think what you've just
spoken about actually is about the
challenges that we're seeing in the
Pacific you spoke about the North
Pacific there North Korea and you're
quite right to highlight some of the
aspects on China but this is actually
about much more than that this is about
a demonstration that democracies like
ours like Australia like the United
States can stand together against the
challenges that we're facing around the
world now you're quite right to
highlight China but there are others as
well Iran and Russia have all in
different ways been challenging the
freedoms that we enjoy to travel to
trade to associate and indeed to enjoy
the liberty of allies that have been
threatened in places like Ukraine and
around the world so this is hugely
important and it will bring jobs to
Barrow it will bring strength and depth
to our nuclear and to our naval fleets
in not just the Pacific but actually
also the Indian Ocean and indeed the
Atlantic the fact that you're bringing
in other countries when we talk about
China it feels a little bit like the
government's saying
don't be too worried about China we lord
West um not that long ago just on the
14th of March said that is it is the the
number one threat and in his mind to
World stability do you not agree with
that well I think the integrated review
that was published yesterday makes that
extremely clear the Prime Minister
describes it an Epoch defining challenge
now that challenge comes in many
different ways you know you have heard
me speak uh about the the threat and the
challenge that China poses in different
ways in different areas and you know in
recent months sadly I've had to work on
closing down some illegal Chinese police
stations here in the UK and making sure
that Chinese citizens who may be
studying here are not being threatened
by the Chinese State and making sure the
British citizens or British Nationals
including Hong kongers are free from
Chinese repression here in the United
Kingdom so this is a challenge that we
are facing at home and abroad and this
is absolutely not something that we're
in any way uh ignoring what it means
however is we must work with friends and
allies and that's why staying in line
with them and working alongside them is
so important that's why the language yes
it matters to make sure that we're
aligned with the United States
and of course Australia which is also
about what we do if you look at what
this package of measures includes yeah
we've spoken about the nuclear boats and
they are very important but we're also
talking about doubling the amount of
money we're going to spend on
understanding China here in the United
Kingdom that means things like language
learning and understanding what's going
on in Beijing and we're also of course
talking about building up our friends
and allies and that's where the work
that the foreign office is doing in
building those Partnerships in Southeast
Asia and indeed in the Pacific Islands
is so important when you talk about
doing doing stuff as well as the
language what about tech Talk would you
like to see Tick Tock banned from
government phones do you think it will
be the Prime Minister asked me to chair
the defending democracy task force only
a few months ago and that's intended to
defend you as well Jane because uh your
role as you know as a journalist is
essential to democracy uh just as mine
as an elected official is and so keeping
those of us and indeed many others who
are part of our Democratic Life part of
our Democratic processes free and safe
is absolutely essential there are many
different apps that you can load onto
your phone I haven't personally loaded
Tick Tock for many reasons you can
probably guess but understanding exactly
what the challenges that these apps pose
and what they are asking for and how
they're reaching into our lives is
incredibly important that's why I've
asked the national cyber security Center
to look into this I haven't had an
answer so I'm not going to give you that
answer yet I can't but as soon as I do
you'll I'm sure I'll be seeing uh but if
their advice was that it is a
potentially a threat you would have no
qualms about saying we should all be
taking it off our phones well look the
different countries have taken different
approaches the Indian government has
banned Tick Tock and many other apps the
US government has taken different
choices in terms of their government
phones different states in the United
States have decided to ban them from
different states phones and so different
companies different countries have taken
different uh approaches I mean what's
certainly clear is that for many young
people tick tock is now a news source
and just as quite right that we know who
owns the news sources in the UK whether
it's News International or mirror group
or whatever it happens to be Trinity you
know it's important that we know who
owns News sources that are feeding into
our phones and Tick Tock is one of them
it's an excellent way to lose many hours
though I've found in terms of children I
find there's plenty of other ways in
social media indeed indeed let's move on
to defense spending we were talking a
lot about yesterday with this integrated
review
um 8 billion was the minimum that Ben
Wallace said he required it looks like
it's it's going to be 5 billion at most
now when we take into account the office
money as well that knocks it down to
about 1.9 million it's not a huge sum is
it do would you like to have seen a lot
more you know I'm a former Army officer
you're never going to hire me arguing
for less money for defense that's not I
pray that's not in my DNA um but the
reality is this is a huge increase in
defense spending and we've got to be
realistic as to what we're trying to do
here we're trying to increase our
defense spending and make sure that
we're more capable of the time when
challenges are facing Us in different
ways and you know the orcas deal isn't
just about nuclear boats it's also about
our own domestic security what it is
doing is it's lowering the cost for each
individual boat for the Royal Navy now
that's a hugely important issue we get
more we get more for our money which is
fantastic and it's also about the way in
which we support our Armed Forces if you
look at the second Battalion the
Yorkshire regiment recently training
with drones you're seeing a very
different kind of infantry to the one I
was used to when I was serving 20 years
ago you know 20 years ago we went into
Iraq and I was one of those soldiers we
didn't have drones we you know if you
wanted a if you wanted an overflight you
had to wait hours if you you know if you
were lucky to get an F-16 or or
something to go over you and and to give
you a forward look now infantry
battalions are able to do that from
drones that capability is a real change
and demonstrates the investment that's
going in that you talk about the imagery
we speak a little Danny yes saying and
that was his concern it was the Army he
said that that is what is being hollowed
out that is where the money is gonna
should be going and it doesn't seem that
a lot of this money's going to go there
well look I hope very much that what
we're going to be looking at in terms of
the Army is making sure that we keep
getting some of the most fantastic young
people joining our Armed Forces if you
look at the way in which the British
army is able to recruit and retain some
of the most fantastic individuals in our
country and help them to serve our
country in many many different ways
actually I mean we talk about the front
line but of course floods and many other
different areas the armed forces have
been fantastic it's really inspiring and
I was lucky enough to be in Tracy
Crouch's constituency yesterday and see
some of the work that the rbli are doing
in order to support any number of
different veterans where they're able to
serve and serve again but if if the
government isn't putting a lot of money
into the army could you understand why
people maybe would think twice about
coming into that service well all I can
say is speak from experience on that and
say it was the most fantastic experience
for me I I hugely uh well I got so much
out of the Armed Forces I got so much
out of the army it was it was a
fantastic experience and I hope many
young people will think about it I mean
for others maybe it's the Navy the Air
Force maybe they're all Marines there
are many many different ways of serving
and and I can tell you now as the
security minister and uh responsible for
some of our agencies the National Crime
agency and organizations like MI5 offer
many many other ways to serve our
country that are truly inspirational and
keep us safe in ways that sometimes
you'll never hear about but uh but are
really fantastically important if before
we let you go the the migration bill of
course I added second reading in the
house last night Theresa May uh made
quite a powerful speech she of course
spent six years at the home office she
said that this legislation on small
boats won't work
um we should be protecting people from
Modern slavery and that this will go
against it do you think we should be
listening to her here I always listen to
Theresa May I think she's a
fantastically important colleague and
actually she's a good friend so I do
listen to her well one of the things
that I've been watching in recent years
and you know I've been speaking to
people in the world food program and
many of our embassies around the world
when I was chairing the Foreign Affairs
committee many of our partners in
different parliaments is that this is a
challenge that we're all facing in
different ways and it's an exploitation
of some of the world's most vulnerable
leading to a level of Cruelty that we
you know is almost impossible to imagine
and we very often quite understandably
focus on that last element that that 20
miles between France and the United
Kingdom that people are trying to cross
actually this is a trade that is
crossing not just France and Italy but
many parts of North Africa leaving quite
literally thousands dead in the Sahara
quite literally thousands dead in the
Mediterranean I don't know whether you
remember Jane but I certainly see it on
my memory that photograph of Elan Curtis
that young boy who was drowned and
washed off on a Turkish Beach you know
this is a
I mean this human trafficking is is
costing a terrible terrible price it's
possible to to absolutely agree with you
but also say that what Theresa May is
also rides May says it's also right that
it isn't going to protect people the
government's plan isn't going to protect
people from Modern slavery well what's
absolutely clear is that every
government has a responsibility to fight
this appalling crime of human
trafficking there's no question about
that
every government also has the
responsibility to see what it can to end
modern slavery and the first thing you
could do to end modern slavery is
separate the those enslaved people from
their captors and that's exactly what
this government's trying to do now there
are huge challenges I'm not I'm not
going to belittle it but no question
that these are very very difficult
things to do but the first thing we've
got to do is stop this appalling
exploitation of some of the world's most
vulnerable people Tom to you tonight
thank you very much thank you
well let's take a quick look at the
papers as we've been talking about the
new submarine cooperation deal between
America the UK and Australia is leading
the times which says Rishi sunak has
done the deal to protect the world
against emerging threats in the decade
ahead
the Metro says that despite the apparent
resolution to the disagreement between
Barry Gary lineker and the BBC there are
still calls for the corporation's
chairman Richard Sharp to resign
the eye has the headline pressure grows
on BBC bosses over Linker climbed down
the graph looks ahead to the budget
tomorrow suggesting the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt intends to raise the
tax-free allowance for pensions by more
than half a million pounds
and the sun reports that the former pop
star Gary Glitter has been put back in
prison for breaching the conditions of
his license
now luck ran out for some drugs Runners
off the coast of Colombia they were
caught with a massive Hall of two tons
of drugs on board let's take a look at
the images the submarine was seized by
the Colombian Navy and sailors had come
across the ship on Sunday whilst on
patrol an extraordinary amount of
Narcotics found there on board
let's get a look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
an awfully wind will make it colder
today but it'll turn mostly mild again
to end the week the rush hour will be
fine for most with a frost bringing icy
stretches to the north but it'd be windy
with wintry showers in the north and
Northwest sunburn will stay mostly fine
into the middle of the day but wintry
showers will develop widely in the north
and west frequent and prolonged over
Central parts
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now the first stamps featuring The
King's silhouette are going on sale and
the collection celebrating the nation's
favorite flowers the uncrowned profile
of the king there he is up on the left
uh here's a passionate Gardener an
environmentalist of course that's
painted in silver as you can see on that
top left hand corner a really beautiful
sweet pea sunflower some of those are
among the Queen's favorites the Sweet
Pea was her favorite the sunflower of
course the national flower of Ukraine
and the lily
and the peony we could go on
now we find out coming up after about
the highly unusual steps being taken to
help with the preservation of an
archaeological site in Pompeii
foreign
[Music]
's greatest archaeological sites and now
it's got sheep trampling all over it but
why well archaeologists at the Roman
city of Pompeii which of course was
buried under a volcanic eruption in 79
A.D have Enlisted the help of a flock of
sheep the idea is that they will control
the grass and the vegetation from
causing damage without the need to use
harsh substances or Machinery to
preserve unexplored sections against
erosion and it's also proving to be very
cost efficient
now the security minister Tom teigenhart
has spoken of the danger the UK is
facing from China and Chinese systems he
was speaking after the UK confirmed a
deal to work with the United States and
Australia to build a new generation of
nuclear attack submarines to help
counter Chinese activities in the
Pacific a short while ago Mr tugenhart
told me that the UK has to be aware of
China's activities
the Prime Minister describes it an Epoch
defining challenge now that challenge
comes in many different ways you know
you have heard me speak about the threat
and the challenge that China poses in
different ways in different areas and
you know in recent months sadly I've had
to work on closing down some illegal
Chinese police stations here in the UK
and making sure that Chinese citizens
who may be studying here are not being
threatened by the Chinese State and
making sure the British citizens or
British Nationals including Hong kongers
are free from Chinese repression here in
the United Kingdom so this is a
challenge that we are facing at home and
abroad and this is absolutely not
something that we're in any way uh
ignoring
well tomorrow Kona is here with me and
and tomorrow he was watching his words
very carefully but I got the impression
that he he would have liked to have gone
further with China I mean Tom Tegan has
been a security minister for a few
months and before that um as a back
bench MP chairing the Foreign Affairs
committee he was very hawkish on the
subject of China he's been sanctioned by
the Chinese government he has in a
newspaper article a few years ago
described China as a threat to our
security in the prime minister's defense
review release yesterday he would only
say that China was a threat economically
and a challenge globally and many in his
party would have liked to see him go
further yes yesterday's defense review
was an update to One released only two
years ago to reflect the fact that over
the last two years China has been a
growing concern for Western democracies
and China was mentioned about 40 times
in that 60 page review but still there
are senior figures in the conservative
party the likes of Ian Duncan Smith who
said the government is asleep at the
wheel on the threat post by China
militarily economically in all different
spheres who are looking at this review
and saying that if the Prime Minister
thinks it's only an economic threat then
it does actually go much wider than that
so I think although they have toughened
up their language on China and of course
this submarine deal the Prime Minister
signed in the U.S yesterday is aimed at
China I think there are some in his
party who say things might get a lot
more concerning in the near future okay
tomorrow thanks
now members of the Scottish national
party have started to vote for the
successor to Nicholas sturgeon and if
they watched Sky's debate between the
three candidates vying to replace her as
first Minister last night they would
have seen each of them run into trouble
so you need a central bank what about
the other institutions you need
what other institutions are you talking
about you don't know
the independent debt management office
right I'm sure as I said I don't have
this full detail on this at the moment
or should be allowed to live freely as
they choose and I do not think that
there should be a that there should be
conversion therapy gay man adult man if
he wants therapy to change his sexuality
should that be allowed or not well it's
it's it's it's his choice and but I do
not think we should allow conversions
Choice well we should not allow
conversion therapy in Scotland what
would you do to deliver for example
economic growth in our economy and why
do you think I'm more trusted to tackle
the cost of living Christ especially you
are that's what I suspect because you've
not had a public service delivery at all
but I've had three of the most difficult
in government over the last 10 and a
half years how are you going to deliver
Independence if the public don't have
confidence in you they do and for three
weeks I've managed to increase public
support quadrupled in fact
well joining me now is the snp's leader
in Westminster Stephen Flynn hi nice to
see you Stephen
um what did you think of of the debate
one of my colleagues John Craig said
that he felt that Hamza Yusuf who you
are supporting was guilty of a bit of
mansplaining right well I've not seen
the debate in its entirety I'll be
honest with you I was Voting last night
against the government's deplorable
Asylum seek our bill but what I have
seen on Twitter uh when I got back to
the flat last night and what I've seen
this morning it's been very similar to
the the previous debates I think there's
been robust exchanges to say the least
uh and I'll uh I'm looking forward to
the end of the contest that's probably
the the best way to put it because I
think it's time that the the SNP moved
on that we focused on delivery and we
focused on the big issues that are
facing the people of Scotland the cost
of living crisis and the challenges
which exist within our Health Service
and Health Services across the UK and of
course how we get to that independent
future
yourself the right person to do that
though we
've put carried out a lot of polls in
advance of the debate last night
um one about Ham's use of himself twice
as many people think that he'd be a bad
first Minister as a good one let's have
a quick look at the the results of that
poll
um
can we bring it up
oh there we are uh who would be a bad
leader of the country uh 44 Hamza you
saw 39 Ash Regan 36 K Forbes
it seems that the public maybe don't
agree with you but no I think comes will
be uh fantastic and the reason for that
is simple you know life is tough at the
moment and people are carrying out for a
little bit of Hope we've had brexit
we've had the pandemic we've had Liz
truss destroying the the economy and of
course we've got the cost of living
crisis and humza's plans in respect of
child care in Scotland are
transformative expanding it to one and
two year olds which is a win-win for
families and also for the economy he
wants to create that green Industrial
Revolution that I'm very keen to see
being in the north east of Scotland I
want to see that just transition that
protects jobs and the climate but
perhaps most important of all I think
you'll bring the Scottish national party
back together he will he will unite us
and lead us to hopefully bigger and
better things you're not mentioned
Independence yet which surprised me I I
think I I did
an answer and because that that's
obviously the the thing which which
defines the Scottish national party
um it is the ultimate goal that we want
to to achieve but we've also got to be
cognizant of the challenges that are
facing people on the day-to-day basis at
the moment you know we've got the
Chancellor's budget and tomorrow
actually and we've not heard from him
yet what his plans are in relation to
energy bills that's the big thing that
people are contacting me about they want
to know how they're going to get by on a
monthly basis they're getting squeezed
whichever way they turn whether they go
to the shops for their food costs
whether it's their mortgage costs or
their or their um or indeed their energy
bills they're getting challenged
everywhere they turn we need the UK
government to take action we've proposed
that they don't just freeze bills that
they cut them by 500 pounds a year
because they have the fiscal Headroom to
do that that's that's the big issues of
the day we should be focusing on that
and I think it's incumbent upon all of
us to be talking about the things that
matter to people in Scotland but the
latest polls again don't show that there
is an overwhelming majority backing
Independence in Scotland
um one that we we carried a Hugo Paul
for sky and used 46 backing and exit
from the UK compared to 54 who want to
stay it doesn't seem that it is the
right time to be raising this again well
the polls for the last couple of years
have generally been there thereabouts 50
50 this way from us being 53.50 well 46
54. that's a big difference isn't it
yeah but they sway from us being on 54
to the north side being on 54 and that's
happened
um consecutively uh and on many
occasions over the course of the of the
last couple of years but that's where
it's incumbent upon us to have a leader
who addresses the big issues that are
facing people at the moment but also
builds that that widespread support
across Society in Scotland for that
better fairer Greener independent future
that we we want to see and I think our
views and values in Scotland are in
stark contrast to those those at
Westminster we have a conservative party
which is going down a track which
frankly I don't think any of us quite
seen coming the right one politics are
emanating from the chancellor and the
the and the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary and of course you have a labor
party which is just as Keen as the
Tories are when it comes to the the
removal of the the UK from the European
Union who don't seem to think the single
Market uh Customs union and freedom
movement is a good thing I want to deny
the people of Scotland their democratic
is no matter which way people of
Scotland turn you have a different shade
of blue at Westminster that's not the
future we want we want a better brighter
future for everyone in Scotland but but
some would say that that the terms of
yourself is in a sense the same shade of
blue for the SNP in Scotland is just the
continuity candidate Nicholas sturgeon
2.0 I I don't necessarily buy into this
continuity aspect I think each and every
politician is their own person and
ultimately what we're going to have is
change I think change is a good thing I
think change affords us the opportunity
to have a little bit of Hope back in our
politics as well but when it comes to
the smps record of delivery in
government it's something that we should
be proud of as something that we we
should celebrate we've delivered a lot
for the people of Scotland over the
course of our tenure in government and
even if you look at some of the
portfolios that Hamza has held when it
came to transport the Queensbury costs
and a huge infrastructure project which
came in uh under budget and and on time
when he was just as secretary he came
was at record laws and of course when
he's Health secretary as he is now
despite the challenges that we all face
in our health services
the UK
um the Health Service in Scotland is
performing the best of all those and
we've not had a single nurses strike on
homes as watch so I think he has a
record to be proud of that's right but
there's real problems with funding isn't
there NHS Azure and Aaron says it needs
13 million to hit its reduced weight in
time it's getting seven point a and it
just highly needs 12.5 million it's
getting 8.3 you know you can go through
all of them they're not getting the
money they need to put it another way it
would require a savings of around 621
million for these trusts to break even
there is an issue with Healthcare in
Scotland and that's down to the SMP
there is an issue when it comes to
finance but of course the levers of
power when it comes to financing these
aisles are determined not in Hollywood
determined that Westminster the Scottish
government operates with a fixed budget
which is given to them each and every
year now there are some tax varying
Powers within that but not to the extent
that would be able to fill the the black
hole the Westminster austerity has has
of course created but the the point I
was making there was that the Scottish
Health Service was performing better
despite the challenges we face and there
are significant challenges better than
all other health services on these
aisles not on these metrics it depends
which metrics
those are the important ones because
that's people getting treated which is
the most important thing and and also
the um there's not been a single nurses
strike I think those are things to be
celebrated and they've happened on on
hamza's watch Stephen Finn good to talk
to you thanks a lot for coming in thank
you
well coming up a mini competition what
do these two men have in common
find out after the break
[Music]
now before the break I asked you what do
these two men have in common on the left
is of course the British actor Sir
Michael Kane on the right music producer
Quincy Jones now if you said that they
work together on the 1969 movie The
Italian Job you'd be partly correct
some days like
these that
I remember
singing songs and drinking whilst
Michael Kane of course starred in The
Comedy crime Phil as Charlie was Croaker
Crocker and Quincy Jones can pose the
soundtrack which features on this song
that song on days like these but that is
not all any other guesses what Milestone
they share today
well they're both celebrating turning 90
years old I cannot believe Michael Kane
is 90. fine gentleman
now a report out today shows that hm
inspectorate of probation has serious
concerns about the effectiveness of
probation work with released prisoners
among the problems recall rates are high
with three in ten prisoners being
returned to custody it's highlighted
this morning by the news that Gary
Glitter has been recalled to prison for
a license breach just weeks after he was
freed well here with me now is the chief
executive of the criminal justice
charity unlock Angela Kent Andrew thanks
so much for coming in and I suppose you
could say that that perhaps the system
has worked if Gary Glitter has been
recalled does it well there are a number
of sides to the system and the report
really highlighted some of the flaws in
it so
um it actually showed that the majority
of people are not being recalled
necessarily because they are reoffending
but because they have other factors in
there so uh four out of ten only four
out of 10 people were leaving prison and
going into settled accommodation and
only eight percent of people who will
work ready leaving prison were going
into work and those are things that
we've known for a really long time make
a big difference to people when they are
leaving prison so essentially that
they're coming out of prison and they're
slightly being cast adrift not being put
somewhere that's suitable or feels like
home and even though lots of them have
developed skills in inside prison those
aren't being put to use absolutely
absolutely it's a huge issue and and we
know employment is one of the the
biggest factors in people
um staying out of prison living positive
lives being able to move on themselves
so at unlock we have a helpline other
people can phone
um anyone with a criminal record and by
far the majority of contacts that we
have with people and that was 9 000 last
year are about employment and the
complexities of doing that are recent
report by the charity working chance
also found that 30 of employers would
not employ anyone with an unspent record
and that is everybody leaving prison at
the moment there are some employees that
are different though I mean I know
timson's for example you know that
they've they've made great strides
haven't they helping people I mean it's
just an extra thing I mean it's hard
enough to find a job for a lot of people
these days but how hard is it to get
back on your feet when when you you've
come out of prison and you've decided to
turn your life around it's incredibly
complicated because people who are in
prison have often got a myriad of of
things that they need to deal with so
we've talked about housing there's
employment but often Health as well so
you may have been getting
um support around drug alcohol abuse
when in prison you're released if
there's no continuity there then that's
problematic people often have mental
health conditions as well and we know
that neurodiversity is an issue for many
many people in prison so that if the
support's not there then they're not
able to take those next steps and in
itself having a criminal record causes
great amount of stigma prejudice and
discrimination so people often have to
live with that for life
is there a sense too that a lot of
people especially if you're talking
about people who are neurodiverse
actually find it easier to be
institutionalized that that actually the
routine of prison and and somebody else
making decisions
helps them and actually that they almost
when they come outside just find it easy
just to go back in
really so you know everybody with a
neurodiverse condition
um is different
um and they're all there's a whole
spectrum of them I have ADHD myself so
um the idea of being told what to do all
the time is is not something that I
would Relish in any shape or form and
often they are not necessarily getting
the support that they need anyway
um why do you think people still
continue to see former offenders in in
the wrong light you know it is hard
isn't it yes I think especially if you
perhaps have a small company and and you
only have you know a few people there
that you can understand why people might
think I don't want to put myself at risk
I don't want to put my staff at risk
sure
um I think there is a a thing around the
language that's used around offending
around convictions
um we hear things on the news from
politicians and it causes stigma for
people but it also feeds into this idea
that anybody who has done anything wrong
ever anyone with a criminal record is
intrinsically bad and has no chance of
Rehabilitation and if we're going to
take Rehabilitation seriously which we
should be because it's for the benefit
of everybody we need to start seeing
people as human beings who can change we
can rehabilitate Angela Cairns from
unlock thanks very much lots more to
come in the next hour
foreign